Daniel Cormier said that the law
Muhammad is the most warranted for a
Welterweight Title shot um nine in a row
right I want to know what your thoughts
on that was and uh why the law is not
getting the next title shot well Daniel
Cormier doesn't make those decisions uh
it's nice of him but uh yeah uh above
all uh we have plans for below
law is going to fight again soon and
then we'll find out who's next in line
yeah so he said he has plans for below
yeah well we know this plan it's a tough
[__] plan it's Chevron right it
should be shock card that's what they
want yeah Jesus but uh it was just funny
how he's like Daniel Cormier doesn't
make those decisions so I I would run
the exact same way if I like that's why
I [__] with Dana like I'd run the exact
time I'm like yeah cool it's not his
call yeah yeah there's a there's a
million other people think that what do
you want me to do when you run the UFC
run it how you want to run it but I I'm
going with Colby what else she got